welcome back to new rock stars nudes
today we got the final trailer for
Aquaman that will also cover some new
footage from the Todd Phillips what can
be next Joker movie and a detail from
george RR martin that really shakes up
the prequel series as we know it I also
got some sweet new kicks inspired by one
of our favorite shows that's coming at
the end of the episode I'm Erik Bosse
joining me today our Sam basher and
built Melina hello welcome to the table
folks yeah here we go let's get started
I'm very excited about this let's talk
about the final trailer for Aquaman had
dropped recently depending when you're
watching this and we got a lot more
Atlantis a lot more Willem Dafoe finally
we haven't even seen him at all and even
a little scene in the coal command kick
in some yes let's get into it first up I
just wanna point out a few things
a Thanksgiving there you go welcome
first Thanksgiving to you let's take a
look at baby Aquaman holding his little
tried and it's adorable hinting to is
that's an awful is that lobster it's a
seafood fork I don't believe so that's
two prongs that's just a weird little
Eric here the wealthiest what kind of
fork is that you eat lobster with your
hands if you're really a glass we also
see a shot of Atlantis before it sunk
under water since the underground
underwater that's pretty fun as well but
the most exciting thing for me was
seeing willem dafoe as volcko he's
teaching young Arthur curried how to
swim properly it's he da Jie looks I
think it's just a good amount of makeup
plastic surgery it's date right now I
mean the more you tie up hair up here
younger than Norman Osborn that's what I
want to be doing when I'm older just
kind of keep pulling and pulling and
pulling until it all gets stretched back
you know taking a look at those
eyeshadows right there let's take a look
at Arthur's boys that's why he's got the
freaky
he had kind of freaky contacts in
Justice League I'll be honest he the way
like they go greenish hue to them and
now there's actually a reason thank you
James Wong so what is the reason so he
can actually see underwater there's like
a bioluminescence to it so you see him
in the trailer close eye open eye with
his hands like that there you go he goes
me like and he does that volt goes like
whatever whatever makes like faking
crime
so that allows them to see things that
would normally be invisible to in like
low-light environments which is pretty
cool I like it's a cool way of showing
just his abilities popping up like I
think the closes would get to this is
maybe like spider-man movies where he's
trying to discover his powers or
Superman when like all of a sudden he
can see through walls or shoot lasers or
something like that so this is cool that
we get a new character and it in the way
it's explored having a mentor I think is
gonna be really fun but let's talk about
other Atlanteans we see we see ocean
master up close and personal Wow boy
howdy he's beautiful yeah he's got a lot
of stuff going on there he's beautiful
no arm I guess that's a mimicking fish
scales yeah but that seems hard to move
in a little bit but that's King Orin
played by Patrick Wilson makes me
excited because I'm glad that they
nailed the helmet because it could look
like a Bionicle if they really bungled
it and I think they actually did a
really good job thank you James want to
look like a crustacean great like a
catfish like yeah like a catfish in a
crab udders sitting right on his face
right there yeah he has his Trident as
well so we're gonna see some tried and
untried in action which to me makes me
pretty excited but on the next photo I
wanted to show is of Atlantis what looks
like the fall that lantus you can kind
of see some like electrical energy also
like one of the fleet's like flying
devices because Atlantis is supposed to
be like a more advanced civilization
before it went under do - whatever
happened guys don't wanna spoil that guy
watch some movie dang it is that water
pouring in a couple different places
yeah it looks like it but I think this
it could be it's I love that this is
like a Roman kind of architecture design
let's see a famously like a Greek idea
right yeah the concept of that one yeah
there you go but next up let's take a
look at Dolph Lundgren it's our first
time seeing him wholly in the trailers
King nearest it looks like he's going to
be the father of Mira over ins Ebel
which is a little complicated to get
into I'm sure you broken it down in
other trailers it's like another
sometimes in the comics it's like
another dimension for aquatic life where
Mira comes from where Canaris comes from
but I like is I'm really digging the way
they're pulling off the hair because
they could look a mite where moves the
way it moves
like they have to do a lot of CGI to
make that look pretty good and it does
look good so far we'll just have to wait
and see how it looks over two and a half
hour because if it could become like
Medusa's hair which is the the works
just like becomes a cartoon almost are
like distracting that yeah I'm also just
gonna reminder said the last time I saw
this guy he was on arrow he was on and
he's just as DC properties are bringing
back this like very awesome actor from a
time and then he did nothing and then
just to DC property was doing a Creed to
he's played well he's playing his
players able to come back also I do dig
his regalia I'm a big fan yeah sure
but also let's take a look at the old
tried and I just wanna point this out
because later in the trailer you also
see them showing off Aquaman in his new
suit in his new Trident they label that
as a Quinn tent and I don't like saying
that I think that's a dot that's not a
fun thing to say no combination is still
abundant yeah it's like the razor wars
or whatever the mock three and then the
four and then the five link is that
better than the three it probably is
probably you got more you get more grip
which is the most important part yeah
it's a smoother shave so the bad thing
probably one shaving of the hair that
way it'd be easier to do it with five of
them into the three of them it's a
scuttle combed his hair they work there
you go so it's very important but next
up let's take a look at Yaya Abdul
Mateen the second as Black Manta before
he gets his costume it looks like here
we're seeing how he's being introduced
into the movie we see some of armed
soldiers looking like they're going to
talk with him on his like personal
submersible device with our vehicle so
I'm they're gonna be worried usually the
story that they've basing this off of it
looks like Geoff Johns is a big Justice
League crossover from the new 52 and
OSHA master and arm work together to try
to take over Atlantis and the surface
world so I could see them working
together and that's probably where he
gets a lot of his gear as well which
would be cool I'm very excited to see
him I like how excited he is seems on
Twitter as well if you guys follow him
he's very excited that he gets to play a
DC character so it's very happy for I
bet that the new 52 interpretation of
Aquaman is the reason why we have an
Aquaman movie and we ever did before
well yeah the people actually for that
and
was like this idea of there being like
warring factions sub that's like super
interesting and taking those Greek and
romans versions but before that it was
not very interesting no there are some
cool elements too like Aquaman but they
usually have to go pretty extreme to
make him interesting like when his baby
died anywho zoals I'm gonna take a look
here at the pulse coming out of
Aquaman's hand which is pretty cool this
is a new thing we've seen in the
trailers it's a little hard to see here
but in the trailer you can see them like
zooming out of his hand kind of like in
the Super Friends carts whenever you'd
like talk to fish which also like it's a
cool way to visualize like he it's not
man I hate when fans do this but I have
to describe it properly it's not like
telepathy it's kind of like this like
deeper influence of sea life like
pheromones like to talk to fish because
they don't have language you know but
you can influence them there you go real
quick look up I think it's whales can
imitate humans making fun of it yeah
second wars with other members of my
species mortgage and then lastly I just
want to take a look at this giant
frickin crab demon coming right out of
the right out of the lava right over
there and you see him also I'm excited
to see alcaman or these forces whatever
taking on this creature it's gonna be
cool there's so many elements from Geoff
Johns the story that they're bringing to
life in this movie specifically like the
deep I believe is what they call my or
the reach there's a trench there we go
thank you they're like the demon esque
like monsters they're so cool and James
Wan is the perfect person to bring this
to life but how does this trailer make
you guys feel about the movie I mean I
was already excited from trailer one
that five minute second trailer that
they put out that actually just had
scenes at the movie not even a trailer
you can't call it a trailer and then
this one it this one was the perfect one
for me like they didn't show too much
and but I wouldn't know what you guys
think it's been a roller coaster ride
for me I've been like not interested and
I'm like oh that actually looks like a
badass mm-hm not interested like so I
mean I'm back in like interested because
I think actually some of this does look
like they're having fun with it and I
guess like the fun always seemed like
part of it but it seemed like was gonna
be cheesy some of it now I'm kind of
like
like I mean I want to see this happen
yeah riding the alligators and the like
the sea dragons and the sharks that's
all I've ever wanted to do it see well
they won't let me know yeah they'll
throw you out immediately from training
I I wish I had only seen this trailer
you know cuz the the past two trailers
one was at San Diego comic-con
I'm almost released at New York Comic
Con they both felt the fanservice II in
different ways and I think this trailer
just kind of took the elements of the
trailer trailers that I like the past
trailers and and edited them together in
a way that I'm like ah yes this is the
kind of Aquaman movie I want to see I
use even the sink of the shot up like
where he catches volcko
spear and then he catches the spear in
the right present-day and it seems like
all right it's like it feels like the
summation of other footage that I've
seen here in a good way what I'm hoping
for is that they still take in the kinds
of inspirations I was just talking about
actually and I've said this before where
like I want palace intrigue I wanted to
feel Shakespearean maybe a bit I think
that paired with like just really
interesting action was really fun when
you get only the action you lose like
kind of the fun story it's like what
battle battle LA like it was like a
sequel like you it stops becoming
interesting if you can't anchor it in
something that we actually relate to mm
same use of the word anchor there some
good nautical I personally hope it feels
as like vast and and open as like the
guardians of the galaxy movies where
it's like no this feels like space it's
like we're not gonna see it all but it
feels like these are this is a city that
operates on its own it's not just here
because our characters are here right
now like nowhere which is cool and for
Atlantis one of the problems sometimes
in comics is that like it they'll say
like no no I we rule all the oceans but
it's a city about the size of maybe New
York which is still impressive but it's
like you don't get that if no one's in
the other corners you shouldn't be able
to claim all of the oceans make this
feel this feels vast this seems like
larger than life and so if we get some
like teases of that or even one of these
creatures going up on the surface world
and fighting some of the soldiers I'd be
I'd be down I'd be interested really
excited to see the world building in
this movie it had some kind of black
panther level at least from the trailer
and the photo jet we've seen so far the
city of Atlantis has the
detail and the thought put into how this
city actually operates on a street level
or a lower water level more than we've
seen in the DC universe so far I throw
out there what you think the Rotten
Tomatoes critic score is gonna be versus
audience score I think based on what
we've heard so far about this movie I
I'd go high eighties like low 90s for
credit score and I think fans are gonna
be happy with it too well I mean if the
critics are up there yeah fans would
definitely be there mm-hmm I feel like
critics are gonna hit it at a nice like
50 - whoo and then fans are gonna be
like 7177 I think it'll be the opposite
I think fans might turn on this in a
weird way and I think critics will like
it more I think we might see like a last
Jedi type thing where critics see some
of the nicer more thought-out elements
that one puts into the movie and then
fans that just doesn't really connect
with them I don't know I could see fans
not really enjoying this movie maybe
because I've been on board since the
beginning Somoza is a bit of a divisive
figure I keep seeing opposite opinions
of people really loving the take on the
character and I've never seen this is
Alban Eric Jason if you have any beef
take it up with Erik Bosse he's got a
lot but I I I'll be one of the people
who loves it I'm sure we love everything
here if we don't like it we don't talk
about it and we don't swallow let's move
on it's a lot of boy howdy doesn't
always come together here I'm already in
the same box I misplaced the other box
but this box does just it's not just
good misplace you took it I took it it
thought I'd needed as a prop and I left
it in my car and now I can't find it but
you know it's we made these things out
of boxes hey if you want to make us a
new box one of you tweeted us a while
ago saying that you would be interested
in designing a box or if you're out
there if you
watchin talk to us yeah tweet at us and
not our off Jersey Council we see it
yeah yeah and let us know if you want to
make a box and we'll give you a huge
shout out one hundred the Ballet's fit
inside that box that's pretty okay so
our trivia question this week is what
other Marvel character has Willem Dafoe
played okay all of our answers are here
in the bucket and as always we'll reveal
the answer at the end of the video and
the loser will have to join our gift
chain that works but we're gonna move on
to some other news that came out this
week another set video from the joaquin
phoenix joker movie came out and in it
we see Joaquin Phoenix's character and
this one the Joker's named Arthur Fleck
and he's being chased by police through
the streets of Gotham and they clearly
know who he is at this point seeing as
they keep you know an Arthur Arthur so
like he's an identifiable person to him
or to them and then he runs into another
guy who's wearing clown makeup in this
footage and he seems like surprised or
confused to see him it is weird we've
seen some we've seen lots of other
people dressed as clowns and set pics
and videos the first one we saw was this
guy Joaquin Phoenix steals its nose this
is like the first video that came out
were like wait they just started filming
this a week ago how are we already seen
set footage it's like there's no one on
security on the set when they're
shooting in New York and they're like
yeah sure paparazzi and normal people
with iPhones or smartphones take video
and put it online we don't do anything
about it anyway
um he takes his phone he throws it he
seems to be and then there's other he
takes knows yeah yeah
he takes it uh yeah they should take the
phones and throw them to keep this stuff
and being out now
there's also some footage of these
people they seem to be participating in
some kind of protests and they're
beating the crap out of a guy in a suit
now
if you've watched our videos before
we've kind of talked about how that
might be Thomas Wayne or someone
important to the campaign if you look at
the signs it looks like there's an
anti-capitalist maybe Occupy Wall Street
Blaine Wayne eat the rich and in this
week I think we've seen a poster saying
like Thomas Wayne is running for mayor
in it so maybe it's like his campaign
but there's a backlash from like
people who make less money and the
Joker's like using that somehow so how
do you guys think all these other clowns
are gonna fit in this story like do you
think maybe the first clown with the
nose might inspire Arthur to start a
clown protest movement that's just a
symbol yeah inspired by that clown but
when I was seeing the the previous image
with the guy who was in it was in the
face makeup it does seem like people
might be choosing to walk around with
you know looking like Juggalos and if
they are then then there's a reason
behind it and then this would give that
reason right where it's just like this
means I'm part of the movement and like
there's a big clown movement I guess
that would be down to see like some sort
of march down the street you know like
but everyone's wearing clown shoes so
they make little honking sounds like
little bike horns adorable but it's like
this is millions of them so it's like
and they're all in unison as they go
down the street I mean do you do you
think it's that - yeah I think it's
interesting because the guy that cast to
play that first clown whose nose he
takes is guys an established actor he's
in that show on Netflix with Jonathan
Groff and he's a FBI gross my mind
hunter yeah he plays a character and
that I believe and he or I believe he
also plays a part in the true detective
he plays the yellow King and the true
detective show on HBO he's an amazing
character actor so it's not just like
some throwaway character they cast he's
gonna have some kind of important role I
believe in Arthur flex journey so
whether it's just I don't think it's
just like a runaway thing that guy
clearly knows him like if you watch the
footage like he calls back to him he
like gets under his skin always runs
around they're partners of some sort
yeah maybe it's their falling-out yeah
like comedic duo yeah now my weird thing
here is that I don't know it's a weird
thing it's just like a reaction I'm
having to this idea of there being a
political movement and an Occupy Wall
Street kind of thing behind the Joker's
motivation is I feel weird about that
yeah because it it feels like I
we were gonna get more motivation than
we've had about the Joker before and
that's the nature of centering a film
around characters you want to motivate
them for some reason why they're doing
it and I know that we all famously like
love Heath Ledger's portrayal of Joker
and how it's like it's unclear right he
likes chaos essentially buddy wants to
watch the world burn my issue with this
motivation is it's so damn specific to
like like I think it speaks to two
people now right a lot of people say
that's why the election went the way it
did in 2016 is that people felt like
they weren't being represented but at
the same time for the Joker that seems
almost too big like I almost would
prefer and maybe it still will be an
internal motivation for whatever reason
and maybe he's manipulating people which
that's what I would see that's what I'm
hoping is like maybe he's taking
advantage of their feelings so he's a
psychopath or some reason and then he's
pretending that you know he's gonna take
care of all the people who aren't making
enough money and our you know don't
having their coalmine jobs or whatever
but I maybe he's doing that I hope he's
doing that but otherwise I'd be
concerned honestly if they're like try
to make him a class hero yeah yeah some
was right yeah Rises but it's the
problem that like that was different
kind of he was kind of a hero then he
had dropped a bunch of nukes on like
that he threatened to like be a false
facade bad guy yeah hero depending on
how late in the movie you start watching
yeah you never got any out how much five
minutes of the movie yeah we did a
40-minute breakdown but no I it's
complicated right because you're tapping
into something that's very current and
also just like well I it's confusing
what kind of reaction you actually want
to see from the audience but for I don't
know at some point you see he's gonna go
super violent and that's gonna be the
end of that and we're not gonna I don't
know if we're gonna learn a lesson we'll
definitely see what what happens with it
and hopefully they keep it on a small
scale rather than making it too
definitive and keep it about the
character but we have some other news
come out this week about Game of Thrones
right yeah I thought this was exciting
because it's a lot of places are
reporting this a little bit differently
and weirdly and I feel like a lot of
people are missing the story here so
George
our homeboy he dropped a new detail
about the Game of Thrones prequel series
people are kind of calling it the long
night actually if you guys remember the
long night I in what we know of it at
least it's kind of like the first
instance with the first winter that they
had to wear I guess are the previous
long winter where we potentially dealt
with the White Walkers and the several
years long yeah and it was this like
endless winter and it's where a lot of
these stories that they tell each other
come from it's essentially like the Age
of Heroes that we talk about sometimes
so the long night in Game of Thrones has
always been referred to as having taken
place 10,000 years before the events of
Game of Thrones ow all right right place
tent out 10 millennia back right so it
means that it would be just these
characters that we barely know anything
about and then potentially maybe this
this the White Walkers again or
something like like that I'll be honest
I haven't been like super excited about
that because it just sounded like a
slightly lesser version of what we just
had in the Game of Thrones series room
but I that I that also would would be
that way because it would have to not be
part of the Valyrian time so like
Valyria when it came to power and the
Targaryens were part of that but what
they were actually not the main family
that came to power in that time they had
their dragons and obviously they had
their their massive takeover of you know
the whole all their continent and across
the way because of the dragons that
wouldn't be part of it if it was ten
thousand years ago which is why I was
getting a little bit bored but George
Martin George armor and just said that
that's probably wrong actually and this
is kind of weird cuz you gotta gotta get
inside his head here for a second but he
is saying that his own characters that
he's written the maesters that have been
talking about you know the long night
for a long time they all say ten
thousand years he's like yeah they're
probably wrong and that is actually
something he's done on purpose because
he's trying to point out they don't have
carbon dating right they don't have
technology yeah they have stories that
have been passed down and of course they
would lose track there was references to
the Bible where how people supposedly
live
hundreds of years in the Bible just to
kind of make the math work oh yeah like
you know a like nine hundred years so
he's actually trying to do a commentary
on that idea of the scholars of their
time being like ours that are just
flat-out probably wrong about a lot of
these things so he's actually saying and
this is huge that if it's it's five
thousand years ago that actually is a
very different time he did say this is a
quote there are no targaryen but then
this is the part of the quote that I
feel like a lot of people are mistress
ponding too he said but Valyria has
hardly begun to rise yet with its
dragons in the great empire that it
built so a lot of people are saying like
like look it up you'll see all these
headlines
oh no dragons in the prequel series and
like no hardly begun to rise that sounds
to me exactly like the birth of dragons
will happen on this show but not least
by the end of the show and now we have a
very interesting thing of you know bran
the Builder whoever like these like
these original men here that that are
gonna be fascinating the beginnings of
like discovering dragons and you the
first time that dragons were used to
take over a whole continent which sounds
fascinating and the White Walkers that
to me is starting to sound like very
worthwhile show so I'm hoping that
everybody's getting it wrong it's also
worth pointing out by the way that Jane
Goldman is working on the show she wrote
on kick-ass and the Kingsmen movies but
specifically x-men 2 and Eisen also so
that would also mean that this is
someone who like its experience with
like you know mutants and and
interesting supernatural creatures I
feel like we're gonna get dragons and
also would be really cool as we get the
real big-ass dragons from the previous
times I mean ours have been pretty big
the ones I have but as big as Apple area
yeah yeah supposedly blaring is it the
dread the dread yeah right it's like was
as big as a big dragon no wow that's big
think bigger I so I I know I've been
talking about I'm kind of just trying to
like I've been like frustrated with the
how I just keep seeing these headlines
and make it sound like it's boring so
that said hopefully my idea is true and
this what this will happen but what do
you guys I need to happen in that
series I just everyone you thrown out
ten thousand five thousand years I'm
just trying to think of like from now
well we have now ten thousand years ago
it's like there's not a there's not a
lot happening in terms of like like
international relationships or like
kingdoms getting along so sometimes I do
tune out but when you start talking
about the world building that you can
get started then like that sounds
interesting to me and also I didn't know
that that one fact that always slipped
by me I agree I didn't know until you
just said it that the dragons were
bigger it before and I was like oh wow
oh so we're seeing like monsters like
this is like this is kinda like Wild
West yeah terms like Game of Thrones
dragons that we've seen are pretty big
they're not actually like a miniscule
version but as the dragons began to draw
a die out they did I think what would
this 'never as small as like a dog yeah
yeah which is adorable but yeah
apparently they were still bigger okay
now remember that line okay the science
of the world of Game of Thrones is
always fascinated me no I like I've
always wondered if 10,000 years imagine
our human history 10,000 years there's a
crazy amount of time where humans work
talk about ancient Sumerians just
building like mud pyramids even before
the Egyptians tuned that technology Game
of Thrones the series where they are
right they're not there's some medieval
times roughly before that they're all
yeah right or whatever your modern day
and we find out the game of Thrones is
actually in the future our time you're
doing some Battlestar Galactica at stuff
Bay yeah no I think it's not crap it's
an amazing show the what what I find
interesting about this people have dug
into like the seasons that Game of
Thrones like maybe that's one reason
that has stalled human technology and
progress if you have unpredictable
roughly unpredictable winters and
summers you get your will be plunged
into a literal Dark Age for years and
years and years and years just when the
Sun never comes up and if you have
things like dragons it's kind of like
when you're seeing like kaiju and like
and those stories and the kaiju slows
down the like the progress of a society
you can't build up cities to be great
when you have a giant dragon monster
coming in to destroy it all the time
I'd love to see like what if kind of
hypothetical society this is why it has
taken so long for the game of thrones
society to crawl out of its medieval
ages because they've had this other
crappy both focusing on that season
think for a second like that even could
affect the whole aesthetic of this show
where we're like those are just gonna be
Game of Thrones repeat it actually might
be more like snowpiercer
oh sure yeah just like a snow world and
they just like oh yeah dark verging Snow
piercer had a time but like essentially
it's just all night all dark it's like
Alaska oh I said live-action Ice Age I
was wondering if Ray Romano would show
up just saying you could have mammoths I
wouldn't be upset just his voice
everyone only loves Ray Romano's voice
that lovely silky smooth voice yeah let
us know your thoughts in the comments
below on what you want this game thrones
prequel to be yeah what your
requirements are for a good yes Ray
Romano fans hit us up in the comments
but in other news this week Rick and
Morty released an official sneaker line
well what boy howdy would you take a
look at that over there where are those
when the next season comes out the logos
underneath the lace so other it's really
just a blue yellow and white snake
[Music]
basically immediately but also bit of an
update to a story that we covered here
previously Thor Ragnarok director Taika
Waititi will not just be directing an
episode of the mandalorian coming to
Disney Plus but he will be directing the
season finale of the mandalorian that
Wow that's significant cool yeah I'm
very excited does that mean it's gonna
be funny
oh you have one season finale what the
whole series has a sense of humor too I
mean Jon Favreau usually has a good
bridge between like the serious and the
comedies a comedy guy I wouldn't mind if
he tapped into that awesome phantom
camera lighting rig that he used for
throw Ragnarok for one scene in the
finale I wouldn't be a mine so his one
of his like team that he worked with a
New Zealand developed a rig as far as I
understood it is that it's a light that
rotates around figures that can be
caught in a phantom camera it's super
slow-motion so that's why you get that
strobe effect or
the Valkyrie flying in to kill hello so
and it's anime it's it's it's new
technology that was created by that team
in New Zealand they use for the first
time in throw Ragnarok so like take it
you got the guy on got him unlock go
ahead and call him up I want to see it
and hopefully get humor but also he got
some epically just van worthy art you
know like in Thor Ragnarok I wouldn't
mind seeing in Star Wars yeah I'd love
to see colour and Star Wars
yeah like well I mean we've seen in
other places but like definitely the
images we've seen so far the sets are
like great it looks like a right yeah
but I mean we've seen the balance like
Abraham's kind of reestablish that kind
of earthy color tone for the right the
new movies would be nice to go I mean
prequels had a lot of bright yeah well
every time they go do in races or
whatever like it goes you know crazy but
at the same time it'd be nice to see a
Mandalorian in that environment
yeah great yeah well now let's move on
to our new rockstars news lightning
round
you guys know how it works you guys were
so nice to tweet us some questions as
always we'd love to hear from you guys
philip has got the questions this week
we're left answer them as quickly
lightening round this one is for
everyone from at Nate the great 24 fill
in the blank
I'd be happy only eating blank for
Thanksgiving dinner three two one yeah
like I was thinking about Oh pumpkin pie
zero
tilda swinton is listed in the credits
for Avengers 4 on IMDB what sort of role
will the ancient one have in the
upcoming movie standing in the
background unmoving not ever blinking
and you don't even realize she's there
until an hour and 40 minutes in so your
official go around me at Bruce gamefreak
what flashback scenes would you want in
Avengers 4 Oh flashback scenes I guess
like like formative times for the
Avengers that were not on camera because
like there's a lot of like implied
relationship stuff that that has
happened between them but I want to see
one like vision and Scarlet Witch ogre
I mean I'm sounding great Tony was
conceived yes I wanna see what everyone
was conceived six one five one if there
was ever to be a crossover event between
Marvel and DC it's gonna happen
sometimes would you rather it happened
in TV shows or movies movies you crazy
I want all that budget I want that sweet
sweet cash also I'm trying to look like
the kid from haunting on Hill House yeah
yeah I thought you were gone forever and
as a group I think at angel Garth 7 it's
Thanksgiving Day in the MCU who was in
charge of cooking the turkey who eats
all the pumpkin pie and who passes out
watching football so who is in charge of
cooking the turkey cap
I mean he's all-american he's gonna know
how to do that I think visions in charge
of cooking the turkey didn't he make
that uh that Russian soup stuff in savoy
he doesn't have like a sense of taste
he doesn't emits Nam didn't say it's
gonna be a good Turkey he may have just
sprayed like crayon shavings in there
cuz she said that wasn't paprika even
though I don't know what he could have
grabbed instead yeah he saw the pumpkin
pie hole um cuz he's big boy I think
Falcon you know seems like he's got an
appetite why cuz Sam Maggie's always
playing jokes on set and he's gonna get
tired he's got Anita who passes out
watching football
Hawkeye I think cap yeah but cap cares
about like leather helmet before all the
brain damage that's been lightning round
thank you
Happy Thanksgiving all right and now
we're gonna move on to our 15 seconds
shout out now is the time we usually do
our 15 second shout outs today I thought
we'd use this segment to talk about what
we're grateful for this year so you can
take longer than 15 seconds if you need
but just this once what do we thankful
for first uh if I may I'm extremely
thankful for being able to work with you
guys there's been a blast for this like
for over a year now which is awesome you
guys have been really supportive and
I've been able to work with a lot of
amazing people in this field that are
share similar interests or teach me
something new about the things that I
love and that's always fun to learn
something new so I appreciate you guys
yeah uh similar I I'm really grateful
for the two of you for mod everybody
that works here who doesn't want their
name set on camera it's such a small
team it's so ridiculously small
there's so little and and yet you know
sometimes you get seven videos and
that's really impressive I'm grateful
for Eric Eric does a lot of hard work
and he almost never complains about it
yeah maybe I'm being a Bream this is a
thanks I'm gonna borrow from next year
and then now you can and then very much
for the people that are watching this
part of this video that means that you
actually enjoy like hanging out with us
yeah and then just finally I wasn't here
when we were talking about Stan Lee but
I am very thankful for specifically him
but also all of these creators who make
stuff that's so good that we can make a
living talking about the stuff oh yeah
that's so who's fortunate to be alive
right now like we could have had been
dead yeah he's still out there yeah
as I'm also thankful for this whole team
and my co-hosts and mod as well and for
all of you who are watching especially
like the fans who have made it out to
come see my show live but my infinity
fan show they've done two of so far like
I cannot believe like I thought like I
you know I'd plug it on a couple videos
on this channel maybe we'd get a handful
of you guys to come but there's been
actually a sizable amount of you who
have like made the trip to find my
theater in North Hollywood if you live
in LA and those of you who live outside
of this city and around the world you
guys have been so nice like reach out to
be like when are you taking your show on
tour like it meets so much that you guys
are watching these videos and commenting
and interacting with us but like to take
that extra step to like actually try to
like find us in person and not do
horrible things but support us in that
regard too it's so great so in addition
to all the things I'm going to say them
thankful for when I sit down for dinner
right now I'm thankful for this
operation and for all of you guys
supporting us and getting to work on
Thanksgiving and Thanksgiving a new
quick shout out to Tommy Bechtold we
love you we'll let you in that door soon
and you can take care of this could be a
five-second head start build a weapon
but let's move on to our trivia question
that we asked as a reminder the loser
will have to join the gif of shame and
have to pull something out of that box
but just to remind us what the question
was it was what other Marvel character
did Willem Dafoe play so let's see what
we wrote as our answers fun fact I saw a
younger photo of Willem Dafoe like first
movie using an action star he could get
it for sure first time were sent out
there how do you get yours yeah for sure
go for it man he's still the kid from
[Laughter]
gross well I got Eric's right here he
played Norman Osborn wise man I got
Sam's and Sam says Green Goblin mm-hmm
but he's being that little kids so I
think it's okay the Queen quality
Wednesday see yeah that kid got amazing
LASIK when he was like fifteen he didn't
have any glasses when I was older go on
oh you're doing that yeah yeah okay and
Phillips says Green Goblin Flash Norman
Osborn which is technically what is
written on the card which yes so we it
sounds like all three of us got it or
some may be closer than others but
judges of the three of us we need a
winner I win who loses on Thanksgiving
make him sad a parent F alright so our
third judge is bulletproof rationale
they've decided that Phillip has won by
having both parts of the answer despite
enormous board I have lost it was I did
not know this but I've good enjoyed our
give of [ __ ] identifies with the rich
character and not the like superval is
he really rich he was about to be out is
he he was one day away from being fired
and unemployed and living on the street
okay so I have to turn slowly into a pig
like in Willow who Maude must have
written this one she did a horrific
scene from the movie willow which it's
the only part of willow I've seen it's
awful she which turns them into pig
monsters so shame shame shame as we keep
going and you can keep going shame don't
got words shame all right thank you guys
so much for watching this week's episode
of new rock stars gee I'd like to thank
Sam back
you can reach them at ab s-- ambassador
at EA moss where the glass is part of it
for glasses comment down below of what
else Eric could look like boy howdy
[Music]
remember you got a gift this thing
sharing around turns video around to
subscribe to new rock stars thank you
guys so much for everything that you
guys did for us which is give us jobs
and a living and hopefully you enjoy the
stuff we give you the deep dives and the
things you love we'll see you next week
give us a pic sound
[Laughter]